What we have discussed so
far are the so-called flat page tables,
where for every page number,
there is an entry in the table.
Let's talk about the size
of such a flat page table.
It has one entry per page in
the entire virtual address space.
Even for pages in the address space that
the program never actually accesses,
such as those pages that sit
between the heap and the stack.
The entry in such a page table
contains the frame number,
plus a few bits that tell us
if the page is accessible.
For example, the protection bits or
a bit that tells us that the page is
not really in physical memory at all.
So the entry in the page table
is typically similar in size to
the actual physical address.
The entry needs to
contain the frame number,
which is most of the bits
in the physical address.
It doesn't need to contain the page
offset that the physical address has,
but it needs to contain some extra bits.
So overall,
if we have a 32 bit physical address,
probably the entry size in
the page table will be 32 bits.
If we have a 64 bit physical address,
probably the entry size will be 64 bits.
So the overall size of a page
table is the overall size of
the virtual memory of a process
divided by the page size.
This is how many entries
we have in the page table,
times the size of a page table entry.
Let's look at an example where the
virtual memory size is 4 gigabytes for
a process, the page size is 4 kilobytes,
and the size of an entry is 4 bytes.
In that case, we get a 4
megabyte page table per process.
Now note, that a process might actually
be using less than four megabytes of
actual virtual memory, because most of
the pages are unused in such a process.
Yet, the page table still
needs to be four megabytes.
So one problem with
the flat page tables,
is that the page table
is reasonably large,
even if the process uses very little
of its available virtual memory.
The other problem with the flat page
table is that if the virtual memory
is a 64 bit address space, so if the
virtual memory's 2 to the 64th bytes,
then we are talking about a page table
that is four billion times this,
which is much larger than
the memory we actually have.
So the page table like this simply
cannot fit in memory if we have a large
virtual address space, and today's
processors have such a large space.
So we need to reorganize
the page table so
that it doesn't occupy this much space.